[Applauso]
facciamoci una domanda ma noi riusciamo
ad essere sempre noi stessi e noi
riusciamo ad essere noi stessi nel
lavoro che facciamo non è semplice
io ho impiegato veramente 32 anni per
capirlo e alla fine ho visto che un po
essere è un po come credere per poi
anche credere è un po come a mare quindi
essere credere a mare non fa differenza
sono la stessa cosa
il problema è essere cosa nell'essere
cosa ora potrà sembrare gioco di parole
e che shakespeare non me ne voglia ma è
soltanto una questione di paura
essere o non essere è una questione di
paura
quello che noi dovremmo iniziare a fare
è cercare di ascoltare il nostro corpo e
capire che durante quei momenti in cui
ci arriva quell'impulso quella
sensazione della paura non sta accadendo
nulla di strano nel mio caso particolare
real mio corpo che voleva dirmi hai
gaspare guarda che rischi anche di fare
la cosa giusta
stai attento che potrebbe essere la tua
opportunità e in questi momenti l'unica
paura che noi dovremmo avere è proprio
che la paura ci abbandoni il problema
però è che essere se stessi significa
accettare il cambiamento ma accettare il
cambiamento significa essere cambiati
accettare il cambiamento ma farlo capire
anche agli altri che noi siamo cambiati
e questo ci spaventa ci spaventa perché
abbiamo tanti timori ma non dobbiamo
perché il cambiamento è la natura delle
cose
la mia storia inizia con un ricordo
vivido vero ce l'ho ancora in mente
avevo forse 78 anni era natale ed ero
giù dei nonni con mamma papà mio
fratello i miei zii parente tutti quanti
insieme e erano chiacchiere un'altra mio
zio mi facevano domanda la più classica
delle domande che si possono fare
un ragazzino di quell'età cosa avrei
voluto fare da grande la mia risposta
l'astronauta chi è che non aveva mai
pensato all'astronauta soprattutto in
quell'età bene immaginate immaginate
cosa sarebbe potuto accadere se in quel
momento qualcuno mi avesse detto ma no
non puoi fare l'astronauta
un dramma un dramma perché in quel
momento quel ragazzino ci chiede
veramente in quello che dice
in quel momento è se stesso
poi noi purtroppo o per fortuna non si
sa ancora
cambiamo cresciamo e nel crescere
iniziamo a proiettarci delle aspettative
oppure forse a proiettare delle
aspettative che gli altri stanno
proiettando su di noi e cerchiamo un po
di aderire e fare quello che gli altri
si aspettano che noi facciamo al punto
tale quasi di cancellare dalla memoria
quel ragazzino che invece voleva fare
l'astronauta
la mia prima grande scelta difficile che
mi ha segnato fu quando arrivò il
momento di proprio scegliere la scuola
superiore
i professori mi consigliarono istituto
tecnico geometra e io vedevo i miei
amici liceo scientifico liceo
linguistico liceo classico che non
volevo minimamente essere da meno
quindi liceo scientifico una catastrofe
fallimento totale
eppure poi mi resi conto che forse era
proprio solo l'inizio delle mie
opportunità
avevo tanta paura paura di cambiare
scuola di non essere nuovamente
all'altezza e di deludere i miei
genitori cambio scuola istituto tecnico
industriale elettronica e
telecomunicazioni
ho imparato ad amare la scuola ma amarla
perché non era soltanto quella fama di
conoscenza era proprio la scuola tutti i
giorni il vivere la scuola fatta di
persone fatta di uomini e quando si
incontrano dei professori che sono e
amano il loro lavoro
lì
le cose cambiano poi successivamente mi
iscrisse all'università università
politecnica delle marche presi la laurea
di primo livello ingegneria elettronica
laurea specialistica e scritto mai
finito perché nel frattempo accade
qualcosa che 91 minimamente preventivato
conobbe la fotografia la mia ragazza
sempre nel periodo di natale mi regalò
una macchina fotografica
quando mi resi conto che il tempo
trascorso sulla macchina fotografica era
almeno di dieci volte a 1 rispetto al
tempo che stavo su libri io mi sono
sentito perso non sapremo più cosa fare
immaginate cosa mi poteva passare tra la
mente quando pensavo a tutti i sacrifici
che i genitori abbiano fatto per farmi
studiare e nuovamente delusione poi però
a un certo punto presi coraggio tornare
a casa mamma papà domani apre la partita
iva da fotografo oggi ringrazio ancora i
miei genitori li ringrazio perchè loro
in quell'istante in quel momento mi
trattarono esattamente come quel
ragazzino che voleva fare l'astronauta
e allora io intrapresi la carriera da
fotografo e fu particolare scusate
perchè in quel momento presi tutte le
mie paure e lì iniziai a trasformare in
albe tramonti racconti viaggi e ad un
certo punto iniziamo a vedere quindi il
mondo attraverso una lente una macchina
fotografica ma la cosa bella è che non
stavo guardando il mondo forse per la
prima volta stavo guardando me stesso e
forse per la prima volta sono riuscito
ad essere quel ragazzino che voleva fare
l'astronauta
e che voleva poi raccontare il fascino
delle stelle
questa è un'immagine un po particolare e
come prima cosa voglio dedicare a mio
nonno che non c'è più è un'immagine dove
si racconta il moto apparente delle
stelle la terra ruota ma se due di notte
iniziassimo a fare tante fotografie e
metterle assieme sono 360 fotografie per
una durata di sei ore
questo è il fascino che alla fine
arrivano i nostri occhi
sono andata avanti però dentro di me
c'era sempre il fotografo è l'ingegnere
e ragazzi sera suonavano di santa
ragione tutti i giorni ero veramente in
crisi non sapevo cosa fare perché il
fotografo voleva i suoi spazi
io non potevo farne a meno però
l'ingegnere bussava porta e diceva ma
tutto questo tempo a studiare cosa fai
lo butti vuoi di ridurre così le
aspettative dei tuoi genitori o di tutte
le persone che credevano in the tante
paure
alla fine e capi per una cosa semplice
chemical bisognava per forza fare una
scelta e quindi io alla fine ottenuto
sia il fotografo che l'ingegnere è di
nuovo dalle mie più grandi paure sono
nate le mie più grandi soddisfazioni
perché proprio mettendo assieme
l'ingegner ed il fotografo ho sviluppato
un software per la fotografia
questo software per la fotografia realtà
quando è nato non è nato con un intento
prettamente commerciale anzi è un
software che mi ero costruito io per
semplificarvi la vita durante la fase di
editing poi un amico un po più d occhio
lungo rispetto a me e mi disse
gasparetto se totalmente scemo grazie
perché io non avevo ancora afferrato
l'idea che se questo software aveva
cambiato la vita a me forse poteva
cambiare a tanti altri oa qualcun altro
proprio rivoluzionare il metodo della e
l'approccio e in effetti aveva ragione
ma di preciso cosa ho fatto ho preso
tante cose difficili le ho messe insieme
ci ho messo su un etichetta con un nome
semplice e quando una persona deve fare
qualcosa di complesso in realtà basta
che preme il bottone
con il nome semplice ma ancora più nello
specifico cosa ho fatto
immaginate in ambito di post produzione
e correzione delle immagini il fotografo
fino a prima era abituato a ragionare in
termini di luminosità o di colore ma in
maniera distinta due cose diverse che
quello che ho fatto è stato esattamente
la stessa cosa che ho fatto con
l'ingegnere il fotografo compreso la
luminosità ho preso il colore li ho
messi insieme ed è nato un nuovo sistema
un sistema molto più ampio molto più
potente molto più personalizzabile
quello che ne nato e la possibilità
quindi di intervenire non soltanto sulla
luminosità ma sul colore nel particolare
caso separare colori caldi da colori
freddi
infatti il nome è tonality marx proprio
perché è una separazione di tonalità
calde o fredde ma la cosa ancora più
bella
venne penne dopo perché appena tirato
fuori questo prodotto tutti a partire
dagli appassionati e professionisti mi
diedero subito gran fiducia
nell'arco di due mesi due grandi aziende
di rilevanza internazionale mi hanno
contattato per avviare delle
collaborazioni e con questa gente
collaboro collaboro tuttora ma la parte
più bella è quella che dovrà avvenire
nel prossimo anno dove sempre tramite
queste aziende
mi occuperò di un nuovo progetto
questo progetto nel mio particolare caso
mi occuperò di analisi e diciamo
manipolazioni delle immagini in ambito
digitale ma per tutto ciò che concerne
un riconoscimento facciale una scansione
dell'iride un calcolo volumetrico realtà
aumentata
oppure realtà virtuale quindi non sarà
più solo applicabile alla fotografia ma
sarà fotografia video intrattenimento
scienza ricerca sicurezza
ecco io quindi finalmente sono riuscito
a mettere insieme queste mie due parti
nota però e menzione d'onore d'onore ad
un'email speciale un ragazzo un giorno
mi invia un'email che mi stava
ringraziando mi ringraziava io non
capivo ancora per cosa poi quando sono
arrivato alla fine ho capito questo
ragazzo non abbia la possibilità di
usare entrambe le mani
aveva soltanto una mano e anche quella
che aveva poteva utilizzare in maniera
illimitata quindi il giusto per
coltivare la passione fotografica un
click e quando ha trovato il mio
software e ha visto che con il mio
software non serviva una tastiera perché
tutto era messi insieme sotto un
bottoncino e lui poteva coltivare la sua
passione con un solo click
a lui ho cambiato la vita
ma perché lui che me l'ha detto che non
ci aveva ancora pensato allora per
l'ennesima volta mi sono fatto mille
domande
ad oggi non vi nego che a casa una
versione speciale del mio software e mi
diverto a dargli dei comandi vocali
quindi chissà un domani cosa potrà cosa
potrà succedere quindi insomma io nella
mia vita ho avuto continui cambiamenti
però alla fine sono stato una persona
molto fortunata molto fortunata perché
sono riuscito a capire che cosa
significa amare il proprio lavoro
io vi faccio un esempio proprio
fotografico perché è vicino a me per me
amare significa svegliarsi la mattina e
andare a fare un alba e fotografarla poi
non ancora sapete come sarà l'alba però
ci credete vi svegliate amati quello che
state facendo e andate a fotografare poi
portate a casa nulla di buono perché
l'alba è stata un po piatta si torna a
casa e il giorno dopo di nuovo lì
risvegliate con la stessa voglia con lo
stesso sapore
con la stessa intenzione ci credete di
più di prima e forse arriva anche la
volta buona che l'alba poi la beccate
quindi per amare è semplice basta
diventare basta essere la versione
migliore di noi stessi basta diventare
quella versione
priva spoglia di paure e noi non
dobbiamo aver paura soprattutto di
cambiare perché la paura sarà la nostra
migliore amica la stessa amica che mi ha
lasciato giusto adesso grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]